[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in peter king nbcsports.com
columnist how big a story was that
though was that like 15 years ago pete
when the nfl just floated the idea of
maybe the super bowl in london
yeah i never really bought it dan i mean
it'd be one thing if some russian
oligarch
uh swooped in and said you know uh
three billion dollars if you play a
super bowl in london
then roger goodell is saying where do i
sign
but i just i i'd find it hard to believe
it'd be like you know playing
you know manchester united playing a big
game at
you know metlife stadium or something it
just seems like
it doesn't doesn't belong and it never
did how much do you follow mock drafts
uh hardly at all because i have to do
one
and i don't want to get stuck in sort of
the kind of group
thing that uh if i see
28 people put the same player
in for a team
you know then i'm gonna say okay well i
better put that guy there
i don't i don't like to do it the only
time i really kind of look at mock
drafts is when i
think that the people who do them um
are really smart and well connected but
otherwise i don't really pay much
attention to them
how do you do your mock draft uh
well today is sort of the day that i'll
i've been
asking around a little bit but it's just
too early
and so today is the day that i have a
list of about 15 people who i call i
don't talk to people on every team
because i don't most people who work for
teams
are not going to tell you what they are
thinking
okay now they have friends on other
teams and they've talked to other teams
and they might say because i always say
what do you know that you think i should
know
you know because really dan i talked to
some agents who were very well connected
um
and then i talked to i try to talk to
there's some recently retired coaches
as well and personnel people who still
this time of year treat this as sort of
a hobby talking to their friends because
you might not be a general manager
anymore but you're still talking to
people who are
and you're they're curious about what's
going to happen too
many and some of whom are in the media
so it's a weird little dance
but you know dan it's funny last year i
had the best year i've i ever had
i got 11 first-round picks
to the team uh in the round now some of
them
i had with trades and everything like
that but
and so i always think that
if i can get like a quarter
of the the picks correct
and everybody said well geez how hard is
it to tell zach wilson and
you know and trevor lawrence well it's
not hard but
most of the picks after that are you
know there's a degree of difficulty with
are you settling in on what the niners
are going to do at three
no that's going to be a weekend call for
me
with hopefully with some people who know
a little something about what the niners
are thinking
as we sit here right now i'm thinking
mac jones but
that's stale and old and
clearly if john lynch and kyle shanahan
have gone to see justin fields and trey
lance
since it was not presumed
but since it was uh
logically deemed that mac jones is the
leader in the clubhouse
who knows maybe they have changed their
minds now if i'm sitting here right now
we're talking i say
i don't think they've changed their
minds but i
wouldn't really i don't know that for
sure
hopefully i'll know something by the
weekend how did you react when you heard
the quotes the comments from trevor
lawrence in sports illustrated where
we sort of talked about the game's
important but not
as important it's not his whole life i
don't know i think sometimes dan
we want guys to
um everybody to have the attitude of
peyton manning
that before he goes to bed at night he
will send
i mean he did this late in his career in
denver i'm sure he did it
in indy too but late
before he'd go to bed at night he would
send some voice notes
on his phone to add to adam gay so at
the time was his offensive coordinator
gay saved them all it's and they're like
you know whatever
45 seconds hey on this play that we're
planning to run third quarter
i think we ought to put this guy into
motion
left to right rather than right to left
and blah blah blah blah
and and i'm not say i think trevor
lawrence is going to have some of those
traits
um also in that story he said
uh i told my high school coach i wanted
to be the best to ever do it
so i don't know dan i guess i look at it
and say
uh until i hear from people who've been
close to trevor lawrence at clemson
who have kind of a raised eyebrow and
said
man i'll tell you what he's he's not a
he's not a worker beer he's not a hard
worker
we've never heard that so it really
didn't bother me all that much
the only reason why it um i took notice
of it was
nobody ever thought that andrew luck was
going to walk away before the age of 30.
and yeah i know he had injuries but they
he had moved past that he was sacked 18
times the previous season they had a
good offensive line
they were starting to round into a
playoff caliber team
and he had other interests and i think
you know you get married you have a
child
um he just walked away so that's the
only reason why
i took note of what trevor said is you
know he was he was the guy who couldn't
miss he was the next
john elway and he walked away i think
you're right dan
but i also think that he would not have
walked away
if every day of his life he wasn't in
pain
and andrew luck could not get over these
injuries that he had
multiple injuries and he just never felt
right and he said why do i need this
i don't need this and i don't think it
had all that much to do with the money
i know him a little bit he's definitely
not a money guy
and it's also why he really hasn't
had a lot of thoughts about coming back
i do think he loved football
but i think football didn't love him
back
or didn't love his body back and i think
it was a lot more having to do with
the pain and discomfort that he felt 365
days a year
rather than some demunition of his love
of football
has anybody talked to andrew luck in
depth
uh the colts talked to him before they
made the carson wentz trade
oh they didn't they did talk to you
about coming back well they talked to
him just to say
hey what's what's your story what you
know what
do you and and clearly you know nothing
has come out about what exactly was said
but i think he had to leave them with
this
impression that i'm not playing football
talking to peter king nbcsports.com
columnist football morning in america
must read for everybody the team
that you're most curious about in eight
days
is who the atlanta falcons
i mean we know the 49ers are going to
take a quarterback
we just don't know which one the falcons
i think are really interesting because
you have
everybody thinks the owner is making
this pick and i can tell you that that's
a lie the owner is not making the pick
the owner doesn't hire a new general
manager and new head coach
and the first momentous decision they
could make
that he jumps the line and says i want
you to take a quarterback
now he's an owner of a team he wants to
make sure he has quarterback certainty
you know for the next 15 years and
and uh but and and they might take a
quarterback but the only way i was told
this categorically
the only way that they're going to take
a quarterback is if
they are absolutely all in that he's
going to be a great player
because dan i i i think you could look
at
because they're going to have to sign
matt ryan to a new deal obviously
after the next couple of years this is
his age 36 season this year
he told me a couple of years ago he
wanted to play into his 40s
just like tom brady so
unless you want to
unless you either don't think that he's
the guy to lead you to the super bowl
or you don't want to have a guy
you know 40 million on your cap for on
average for the next
say five years uh you can save
on average probably about 30 million
bucks a year once you get rid of matt
ryan
by having a quarterback on his rookie
contract it allows you to do so much
more
but my feeling is that they have so many
choices they could go quarterback
they could go generational tight end or
they could trade down and i
i'm fascinated by the falcons right now
what are
jerry jones and his son stephen doing by
this
outward fawning over kyle pitts they're
they're
they're at number 10. is it just they
just want to they like to talk or like i
wouldn't tell you what i truly like
but i'm trying to understand their logic
if there is logic here
in 2016 when they drafted
ezekiel elliott in the first round and
they drafted uh
dak prescott in the fourth round you
know i had access to their
to their draft room that weekend and the
one thing i learned
is that jerry jones has the ability
to play the trump card okay he
desperately wanted paxton lynch that
year
desperately and stephen jones was on the
phone for
70 minutes before paxton lynch
ended up going to the denver broncos in
a trade
and jerry jones was just despondent at
missing and
and so anybody who says ah jerry is
going to tell him hey we're
we're going up and getting kyle pitts
i'm not saying they're not going
up to get kyle pitts but the price to
get kyle pitts
is that number one pick plus next year's
one
all but certainly so if you're the
dallas cowboys
and you have great weaponry on offense
do you want to trade your next two ones
in order to draft
a tight end i mean i just can't see it
they're better off sitting there and
getting a tackle with their offensive
line
kind of being a little bit in tatters
now they need to protect that
prescott if i were them i'd sit there
and take rashawn slater
if you had to bet and what the patriots
were going to do
no dan i i
i give up you know i wrote the other day
that bill belichick
has honchoed 25 drafts
he's never picked a quarterback higher
than number 62.
how amazing is that not only is he never
picked a quarterback in the first round
he never picked a quarterback till the
end the highest he ever picked one
was at the end of the second round
so that would seem to tell you well
they're not taking a quarterback
well did you ever think they were going
to spend 8 gillion
on free agents i didn't and they did it
this year
so i think all bets are off with the
patriots i will not be surprised to see
them trade up to
i don't know seven eight nine ten
whatever
to to pick whatever quarterback is on
the board
or i wouldn't be surprised if they just
sat where they were and then in the
second round took kyle trask
those kind of things wouldn't surprise
me you can join peter
nfl network steve weiss as well as
espn's mike tannenbaum
and matthew berry tomorrow night at 8
eastern they will preview next week's
draft during an online fundraiser
benefiting the youth literacy program
it's called write on sports the event is
free to watch
donate throughout the show go to
wrightonsports.org at
eight eastern help change the life of a
student
near you it's a good idea who came up
with this idea pete
ah this is a brilliant thing byron yake
who's the former associated press sports
editor retired and wanted something to
do with his life
and byron said i want to help adolescent
kids who are falling behind in school
in writing and reading and so he said
what do these kids want to write and
read about
sports boys and girls and so
he has changed so many lives over the
last 15 years i'm just
i really appreciate you you mentioning
this and i i'm
thrilled to be a part of the program
it's called write
on sports w-r-i-t-e right
on sports dot org eight eastern tomorrow
night
with peter mike 10 and bomb steve weiss
from the nfl network and matthew berry
pete have fun great to talk to you we'll
talk to you soon thank you
thank you dan